good God I swear I'm not as cool as some
other people I know some people get on
they're like I have a guitar that I
bring everywhere I bring my dog I don't
have any of that stuff I have a pen I
have an inhaler I live my life
hey what's up GQ I'm Jacksepticeye and
these are my essentials
this is Throat Coat tea or as I like to
call it the throat goat that's what they
call me
yeah he got it I got put on this from I
did a tour with the game grumps it's a
2017 maybe and I had never heard of it
before but to kind of like keep your
voice nice supports throat health
so it kind of like coats your throat as
it's cold keeps your voice nice if
you're talking all the time but
especially when traveling because when I
travel I tend to get sick you Americans
love your air conditioning and it's dry
everywhere how most of you don't have a
sore throat all the time I don't know
every time I come here I wake up and it
feels like I swallowed glass
foreign
this is my uh my ventolin 100 micrograms
salbutamol sulfate yeah shout out
illness I have asthma so I have an
inhaler with me all the time I also have
like a steroid one that I take uh during
the winter because the winter months are
hard on us little baby Longs so I had
this one that I take like all the time
when I was a kid I used to take this
twice in the morning twice at night and
then a brown inhaler I don't know what
was in it I turned 18 and they were like
you weren't supposed to be taking that
that much and then I was like oh and
they're like yeah you don't really have
asthma anymore I was like I did it I
beat the system and then a couple of
years ago I started getting Wheezy again
because I guess I'm getting on in years
the wheels are coming off so I had to go
back on my inhalers I'll give you a
little demonstration
[Music]
oh
that's it
foreign
[Music]
but it has an e at the end so is it
Moleskine they're just weird they're
European this is my notepad or one of
Manny that I bring with me every now and
then I'll get an idea for something if
it's a video or I'm trying to do stuff
with this like whole universe of
characters that I'm doing and I I like
having a notepad with me to write stuff
down because I I could do it on my
laptop but I don't like doing that I
like writing it out I like having like a
pen and paper because I feel like it
like gets in my brain more or I like
work it out more that way if I'm writing
it on my laptop I tend to forget about
it and I hate having a messy desktop so
it just gets shoved away in a folder
somewhere so I like having a notepad to
write ideas down at the start of this
one has like if I did a new tour what
would it look like and it's like anytime
I have any sort of idea I just pop out
my pan on my notepad and I write it down
and more often than not they never come
to fruition but I just like having a
notepad I I every time I go to a store I
like a stationary store I'm like I want
to get a notepad I I have nothing to
write in it and I have like five at home
that aren't even filled yet but I like
having it I also write like games into
this if somebody gives me a
recommendation I'll write down like oh I
should play this and play this and then
kind of like write out why I should play
and things like that so I don't know I'm
a very disorganized person normally but
this is like some semblance of
organization in it somewhere I guess
[Music]
this is my laptop which is a new Macbook
Air MacBook and something I don't know I
bought it new and I really like it
because I used to have an old one that
was much bigger and bulkier and because
I traveled so much I always need
something to just do work I do
thumbnails on this I edit videos I get
stuff ready for my content and sometimes
I just watch movies on it or shows so I
bring this everywhere with me whenever I
travel and I love how small it is
because now it's tiny and it's really
light and the one I had before was
Stronger but it was so bulky that I
hated carrying it it gave me a headache
every time I put it in my bag so this
one is Tiny and I love it I could just
sit here and my videos are actually up
on it right now you can see my whole
Channel ready to go because I needed to
get videos ready for today so I was
using it this morning
uh these are my headphones Apple airpod
Maxes I really like these because the
noise cancellation of them is really
good I used to have a set of Sony
headphones that I used all the time but
their new ones are not as comfy and I
wanted to try these out and these have
probably the best sound for any of the
headphones that I've tried like
Bluetooth travel headphones because
we're on the airplane a lot and we're
traveling quite a bit I I like having
headphones that have noise canceling in
them but they're quite heavy so I
they're not really for everybody but
they they are some of the comfier ones
that I've used people in the headphone
space are quite particular about the
headphones that they use so I'm I'm
sorry I'm sorry if there's better ones
out there that I haven't used this is
all I know okay it's either I'm
listening to stuff on my computer or my
phone if I'm watching a TV show or a
movie or I listen to some podcasts but
sometimes music on the way here this
time I was re-listening to Lincoln
Park's Hybrid Theory and Meteora because
I got the 20th anniversary edition the
like 200 one and I was so hyped about
that and it came about like all the
vinyls and the discs and the artwork and
everything and I was like well I can't
listen to that on the plane so I I was
listening to those albums again and it
brought me back to my childhood
[Music]
for Apple at this point look it's it's a
convenient ecosystem that works well uh
this is my phone the iPhone 14 pro I
guess this one is under someone at my
door my ring doorbell is going off so
whoever that is hopefully it's someone
that's not supposed to be there I
said an Essentials video if they don't
bring up a phone then I don't trust them
everyone has a phone it's like who are
you contacting with some people come in
it's like no I bring my
my dream catcher with me or something
like yeah sure you do everyone brings a
phone with them everyone needs to be in
contact with the world at all times so I
feel like this is like the one essential
is this like the one thing that
everybody says they bring pretty much
across the board yeah this is like the
one common denominator of humanity right
now I don't know if that's a good or a
bad thing but I mean why wouldn't you
have a phone I need to go on socials
with it I need to check my videos I need
to contact people here and whenever I'm
traveling if I don't have a phone I'm
lost what else am I gonna do
this is very different all the other
ones are like
nice and cool and it's like wow what a
cool personality he has this is just
moisturizer this is Cetaphil Pro oil
control moisturizer with SPF 30 in it
because I get I get an oily T-Zone
you know you're still watching right
you're still listening I never had like
a skincare routine for my whole life
which I probably should have had I feel
like everyone should have some sort of
care for their skin because whenever
people look at like Paul Rudd and
they're like why does he look like a
baby still it's probably because he uses
something like this every single day I
remember watching tick tocks of like
ever seen those ones with like the
dermatologists and they're talking about
stuff that you should do for your skin
and there's like peptides there's
vitamin C boosters there's retinols and
I do use all of those as well I have
like a vitamin C booster that I do in
the mornings and then I moisturize and
then at night I have a retinol night
cream that I use that's why this baby
face has stayed pristine for years the
one common thing that they kept saying
was that no matter where you go you can
live without that stuff but you should
always have an SPF moisturizer with you
because my skin gets really dry after a
shower and even if you don't have
sunshine in your life like England and
Ireland don't have you should always
still have an SPF on you whatever you're
doing because that's how your skin stays
youthful and exuberant and I'm here for
the Long Haul baby I want to make in
videos in my 60s and I'm going to still
look the same I'll just have longer
grayer hair
precise V5 RT pilot pen again because I
write so much all the time this is brand
new as well this is because my other one
ran out this is one that was recommended
by a friend again because I have a
notepad with me everywhere I go and I
want to write stuff down I I hate my own
handwriting and I normally hate writing
my hand gets tired all the time but for
somebody in this pen Glides like a dream
baby you know how people are like what
you got you got a V8 in that bad boy
yeah you got a car you got a V8 engine
twin turbos like no I got a precise V5
baby this is gonna take us to the Moon
can I get a whoop whoop
this is my whoop watch which I recently
got into in the last like six months
and I love it because I used to have a
Fitbit and I didn't really like the app
how that one works I used to have uh an
Apple Watch but I hated how distracting
the screen was all the time because I
I'm a monkey's banging symbols in here
and every time something would show up
I'd be like what's that and then people
I was around would be like oh you need
to be somewhere I'm like no I've just I
just have I have ADHD I need to like
look at everything that pops up and most
times it was like oh someone's at your
door giving you spam mail but I got the
whoop watch because I watched another
YouTuber podcaster named Cody Co he was
sponsored by woop at one point and he
showed off some of it and I was like
dude that looks exactly like what I want
and I love it because it's all in the
app and the app is so straightforward
and it tells me how much I've slept what
my recovery is like can you pass me my
phone let's see what my recovery for
today is shall we I have 81 recovery and
I got 87 of my sleep 7 hours and 11
minutes and my health model monitor I'm
all in the green baby my heart rate
variance is at 54 milliseconds my heart
rate's at 62 bpms right now I thought
that would be higher
[Music]
another thing I use all the time is I
have earphones at home that are like
noise canceling sleep earphones called
the Bose sleep buds because I'm so
sensitive to noise when I sleep that I I
need like something going on in the
background at all times something to
quell the noise if I'm ever somewhere
where there's like cars honking outside
or something I put those in and then I
play rain sounds on them and then that
puts me to sleep real quick and I think
I've like pavloved my way into falling
asleep quicker with them because now I
put them in and my brain hears rain and
it's like oh it's sleepy time let's do
that so now I actually go to sleep
quicker than I ever have in my entire
life because I use those and then the
world could be ending around me and I
will have no idea
[Music]
well those are my essentials uh some of
you might relate very heavily to them
some of you might not some of you might
think I'm a raving lunatic who cares
it's my essentials not yours what are
yours okay oh I need my teddy my toy
thank you guys for watching thank you
for having me this has been very fun
those are my essentials I'm
jacksepticeye signing off bye bye